and then actually in some really big and
very good cultural news Joe Rogan
according to the Wall Street Journal has
secured a $250 million multiplatform
deal with Spotify the reason this is
really really good news is the deal
basically says that Rogan's show will be
everywhere YouTube Spotify anywhere but
Spotify is now going to buy the ad
rights to the show so that they can
basically sell ads against his show what
does that mean Spotify believes Rogan
and whatever controversies may arise in
the Press from his guests is is not
going away and is profitable they don't
think they're going to lose money on
this deal and it's good for everybody
else because if Joe Rogan leads the way
Spotify is basically saying we're going
to put $250 million of our money up
front because we think we'll make more
money on this basically it's it's Paving
the way for everybody else who produces
content it is much more likely that
comedy and you know offensive kind of uh
uh content will not be taken down moving
forward because these platforms are
banking on it